Evo Grand Finals are some of the biggest
most important matches played for any
fighting game in all of the years of
Street Fighter 4 at Evo gamer beat the
best performer they provide some of the
highest prize payouts sure but they also
provide a look at the absolute highest
levels of competition two of the
greatest players in the world facing off
with everything on the line after having
run a gauntlet through some of the
toughest competition they've ever faced
Evo grand finals are where the magic
happens
what is next and sometimes that magic is
made all the more powerful by something
outside of the players control sometimes
everything goes wrong and the most
important match of the year also becomes
the craziest gonna have to climb the
steepest mountain taken down once again
to tournament point from momochi he has
to win these two rounds Oh No
[Applause]
no jams not like this not like this no
in 2015 UK momochi was on top of the
street fighter for world he had won the
2014 Capcom Cup but he didn't rest on
his laurels he attended and dominated
plenty of events on the 2015 capcom pro
tour and off circuit tournaments he won
shadaloo showdown and South by Southwest
and then placed second at final round
the Topanga world League and stunfest
simply put momochi was one of the best
players in the world heading at the evo
2015 meanwhile a perennial underdog was
having a pretty good year of his own
brueski or bashang narrowly missed out
on attending to 2014 capcom cup finals
being there crushed and he even
considered retirement
gamer B was long considered Taiwan's
finest Street Fighter 4 player and he
always showed up at Evo 5th in 2010 17th
in 2011 2nd in 2012 and 9th in 2013
refusing to put off the uppercut and
that could be the end of him points
gayer be pissed in the air and bucco the
master of style gets styled on new
players hand that level of consistency
and despite missing Capcom Cup theory
was still one the best in the world he
just wasn't the international champion
that players like momochi won in fact he
were me placed just behind emoji a few
times that year third at South by
Southwest and 5th at stunfest he was
having a solid year just not the best
but gamer B always showed up at Evo but
Moshe had a pretty uneventful run
through the bracket beating gackt and CN
to make top 8 meanwhile gamer be made a
pretty clean run through his pools with
only a handful of wins over notable
players like Doc oh and Pepperdine
unfortunately things came to a
screeching halt when gamer be faced off
against infiltrations infiltration and
gamer B had something of a history an
Evo infiltration capped off his 2012 win
by crushing gamer 300 in the grand final
this might be the smart thing for me to
do Oh No
almost with a raging demon button it's
such a killer everybody and well things
were closer in 2015 they still didn't
swing in gamer bee's favor that's it
Evos Luthor's racket is one of the most
dangerous places and fighting games you
suddenly have to play twice the number
of matches to make it a grand finals and
past pools it's full of sharks and game
women got thrown in with one of the
biggest sharks out there wow this is a
this is a match that qualified for top
eight it is gonna be Daigo Umehara
against aver media's gamer p-funk oh one
of these guys is not making top aides oh
it finds it it's critical drummer B is
gonna move on is gonna move on to this
game three
does he have it gamer be playing so
smart Elena where the most difficult
enters to its act going out those shorts
so far for gamer B
humor be made top a but he still had a
mountain to climb
fighting knuckle dude he's running out
of life that is still 8.0 just the
uppercut from gamer beat
taquito oh no that could be it that
could be it for Tito to his demons and
mo he pays the price there but he won't
go there such respect to earn his spot
in losers finals up against the man who
put him there
infiltration and honestly infiltration
can probably be considered one of gamer
B's demons infiltration and Beamer be
played a grueling 30-minute set thanks
in part to gamer B's pick Elena and her
healing ability Alana's ultra - known
simply as healing restores up to 1/3 of
her health based on how long she joins
him and she builds the ultra meter to
use it based on the damage she takes
during a round yeah that's right
she takes damage to feel her healing
which gives her more health to take more
damage to heal all over again
that's exactly what he wanted got just
enough help back while I was able to get
some extra damage and y'all have to base
Eddie to get a counselor no he just
robbed and only asleep lettuce the mind
games the establishment of which
carefully switch character may be
changing as we watch oh and then just
the crouching jab but implications did
not bite oh wow yeah
what's a position challenge wow you can
do it alright - forward good challenge
another reset could it be enough
[Applause]
the final game whether great champions
what everything looked like it was going
here maybe his way suddenly it is turned
around but after both players switched
to more aggressive characters he movie
came out on top with one last timer scam
and a Murphy get done he's denying
denying epic enough time Tuesday his
life you want the timer standing
one of the most mentally draining
matches of a fighter I have ever
witnessed at a competitive stage at this
level
he Murphy played the longest set of the
tournament but he still had one more
obstacle momochi who is sitting in Grand
Finals after beating Tokyo and
infiltration and was poised to take the
entire tournament but game Rumi was on a
roll oh that's so risky Wow doesn't get
a chance to get behind and catches him
out of the air at the top gamer be
making all the right calls even on that
throw tech that we just saw mm oh she
looks like he's playing just a few
frames behind just a few behind the pace
he's not quite able to hang in there so
far but he's far from out of this whoa
no uppercut there that's one of those
just uppercut if you can deny the
bracket for the second set of grand
finals
momochi switch to evil Ryu a character
who could dish out a lot more damage
those are the easy combo smart stuff in
the mochi takes game 1 and while it
worked for the first round he will be
continued to trade games with momochi
it's a danger chip his life he has to
get closer to standing forward deny
unbeatable all right
and it's going to be to one formal mochi
[Music]
mochi tournament board as you can see
the light training out of game repeats
the last chance delayed wake up son
super yeah look deep inside not anything
a rabbit must come out of a hat that
could be enough pull this humor right
down to the line not kill what is next
is taking it to file the maximum
distance the pressure so high
knock-down follow ups have not been
getting paid off here comes the mochi
while momochi took the first round of
the last game both players were so close
to victory with all the pressure in the
world on their bats the unthinkable
happened taken down once again the
tournament point from alone - yes to win
these two rounds oh no no no James no
James not like this not like this no
just as the second round of the final
game started momochi stick disconnected
evil rules state that in the event of a
pause intentional or otherwise the
player who caused the pause has to
forfeit the rounds just stop you come
down lower to help so he could not build
any more meter but momochi had other
problems momochi didn't just paused the
game his stick broke which according to
his manager at the time Antonio Xavier
caused something of a crisis for his
team all of a sudden I'm sitting there
like oh my god where the rest of the
guys I need a spare stake I need
something that momochi is comfortable
playing on from a mochi the issue is a
stick breaking but for gamer bean he had
a ton of momentum going into grand
finals but he was mentally drained
he had just played the longest set of
the tournament and now he was stuck
waiting taken out of the game unable to
stay warmed up I I can't imagine what
they're going through
back in the Evil Geniuses camp Ajay and
Momo cheese partner Cho ko Blanco were
struggling to find a new stick when the
unthinkable happened so I jumped up out
of my seat
ran through the aisles ran into Cho ko
who was doing the same thing running
through the aisles of evo yelling does
anyone have a razor stick no one had one
so we went back to main stage after we
run through the entire Convention not
finding a single razor steak I see
taquito come up and give him his stick
Tokita who both gamer b and momochi
defeated to make it to grand finals gave
his stick to momochi and with that stick
in hand after 5 minutes in
18 seconds that must have felt like an
eternity both players got back to the
match but the time will now
[Applause]
they'll be opening please found that
focus and Marucci will not be pushed off
looking through that wake up uppercut
funds it debate it out from me from
interview as well
tensions are so high now back to the
neutral game they both fired out right
at the beginning bull shooting hard
representing the fireball that he needs
to control that space and keep him out
of that stand round house range but on
the same time endangering itself by
throwing up
a little bit a little bit slower ology
[Applause]
momochi emerged victorious and gamer be
ever the bridesmaid stayed second he was
comforted by infiltration and then his
partner Juliana who is in tears over an
Evoque gamer B was finally so close to
winning her gamer be a lot of respect he
can come out of this and I think a very
good position 2015 with Street Fighter 4
last year at Evo and well 2016 gave us
an incredible Street Fighter 5 top 8
gamer we didn't make it he was put in
losers once again by infiltration but
despite all that gamer B is still going
to tournaments Street Fighter 5 might
not be his favorite game but gear B
always has the potential to come up huge
to play the underdog and triumph over
impossible odds gamer B is one of the
hardest-working most beloved people in
the FTC and an ebow even if he doesn't
win he always shows up thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]